seul lui tous les jours une île une
solution de la gym je commence à craquer
parce que j'ai en fin de tournage de ces
vidéos
une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours et
à chaque fois en début de vidéo je vous
donne la solution de l'énigme d'hier si
vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier
allait la regarder puisque la solution
elle tient en une seule phrase
et si vous l'entendez vous ne pourrez
pas la résoudre c'est clair ce que je
dis je crois la réponse à l'énigme
d'hier et qu'il faisait jour tout
simplement c'est pour ça qu'il a pu la
voir
j'aime beaucoup ce genre d'énigme parce
que comme on focalise sur les points de
détails on en fait une conclusion mais
une conclusion erronée qui tient sur
rien c'est simplement qu'il faisait jour
je vous laisse là dessus et vous emmène
tout de suite sur la prochaine énigme
c'est ehning numéro 18 m'a été inspiré
par un ami à moi qui s'appelle js qui
s'appelle jean sébastien jean sébastien
si des fois tu regarde la vidéo tu seras
pourquoi j'ai pensé à toi l'énigme est
la suivante avant-hier js avait 17 ans
l'année prochaine il aura 20 ans comment
est ce possible
je répète avant-hier js avait 17 ans
d'année prochaine il aura vingt ans
comment c'est possible je vous donne un
indice en ou plutôt un nom à dix ça n'a
rien à voir avec les années bissextiles
ne cherchez pas de ce côté là c'est pas
ça du tout c'est beaucoup plus logique
que ça si vous trouvez la réponse ne dit
pas dans les commentaires ou dites-nous
juste j'ai trouvé mes 2 2 n'est pas la
réponse pour pas dévoiler aux autres qui
chercherait par contre laisser un pouce
en l'air pour nous faire savoir que vous
avez trouvé la réponse pensez également
à vous abonner à la chaîne avant de
partir est passé de bonnes vacances
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
oui